Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Peut-on vraiment se fier à ce que l'on voit de nos propres yeux ?
Pas sûr.
Regardez ces deux traits rouges, on est d'accord,
celui-ci est plus petit que celui-là.
Eh bien non.
Il suffit de masquer une partie de l'image
et vous constatez qu'ils font exactement la même taille.
C'est ce qu'on appelle une illusion d'optique.
Allez, aujourd'hui spécialement pour vous, j'en ai sélectionné cinq
parmi les plus bluffantes.
Vous vous souvenez certainement de cette robe.
En 2015, elle a rendu fou des millions d'internautes.
Personne n'arrivait à s'accorder sur sa couleur.
Tu veux dire la fameuse robe bleue avec des rayures noires ?
Tu veux parler de celle-ci ?
Sauf que moi, je la vois
comme ça, blanche, avec des rayures jaunes.
Alors, selon vous ?
Lequel de nous deux perçoit les bonnes couleurs ?
C'est moi. Toi, t'es complètement miro.
À moins que l'on ait tous les deux raison.
Tentons d'y voir plus clair.
Bleue et noire, blanche et dorée.
La réponse ne se trouve pas sur la robe, mais dans notre cerveau,
car c'est lui qui fabrique les couleurs au niveau
de l'aire visuelle située à l'arrière du cerveau.
À cet endroit, il agit comme un véritable logiciel de retouche photo.
Il devient capable de corriger
lui même l'exposition,
c'est à dire, l'intensité de lumière reçue.
À ceci près, que chaque individu effectue cette correction à sa manière.
Résultat, certains voient la robe bleue et noire,
d'autres, blanche avec des rayures dorées.
Si vous n'avez pas peur des fantômes, vous allez adorer cette illusion.
Il me rappelle quelqu'un, celui-là.
Commencez par fixer pendant 20 secondes
le point bleu au centre de cette image.
Très important : ne détournez pas le regard et ne clignez surtout pas des yeux
Allez, vous y êtes presque.
Attention, je vais maintenant laisser place à un fond blanc et voilà.
Mon fantôme se manifeste.
Je le savais bien que c'était lui.
Vous pouvez même cligner régulièrement des yeux pour faire perdurer l'image.
Alors, je vous rassure, il n'y a rien de surnaturel là-dedans.
Cette illusion illustre le phénomène d'image rémanente.
La représentation persiste après la disparition de l'objet qui a produit l'image.
Ce phénomène bien connu porte un nom : la persistance rétinienne.
L'image se forme sur la rétine
et ne disparaît pas immédiatement.
L'illusion fonctionne grâce à la surstimulation des cellules
qui composent les photorécepteurs de nos yeux.
Dès que l'on détourne le regard, le cerveau interprète les signaux reçus
et compense en inversant les couleurs.
Le négatif devient alors positif et mon fantôme apparaît.
Attention, les yeux toujours.
Voici maintenant
l'illusion de la danseuse en rotation.
Regarder attentivement cette danseuse.
Pour moi, elle tourne dans le sens des aiguilles
d'une montre.
Bah !? Change de lunettes,
elle tourne dans le sens inverse.
C'est étonnant, non ?
Nous ne voyons pas du tout la même chose.
Pour les uns, la danseuse effectue une rotation de la droite
vers la gauche et pour les autres, de la gauche vers la droite.
Maintenant, concentrez-vous bien et imaginez qu'elle change de sens.
Comme par miracle, certains la verront inverser sa rotation.
Alors je sais, il faut parfois un petit peu de temps,
mais ça peut fonctionner.
Ça y est, vous l'avez ?
C'est dingue.
Vous n'êtes pas fou.
C'est votre cerveau qui vous joue des tours.
Arrêtons-nous un instant à ce moment précis de la rotation.
Vous remarquerez que la silhouette noire, au milieu, ne laisse aucun indice
pour savoir si la danseuse se trouve de face,
comme sur l'image de droite, ou de dos,
comme sur l'image de gauche.
Inconsciemment, votre cerveau choisit l'une ou l'autre position
et en fonction de son choix,
la danseuse tournera donc dans un sens ou dans l'autre.
Mais cela n'explique pas pourquoi certains réussissent à la voir changer de sens.
Alors, regardez de plus près.
Vous voyez qu'à gauche, la danseuse apparaît légèrement du dessus.
À droite, en revanche, on la voit légèrement du dessous.
Eh bien, notre cerveau n'étant pas habitué à voir les choses du dessous,
aura tendance chez certains à forcer la vue du dessus.
C'est cette correction qui provoquerait le changement de perception de la rotation.
Cette danseuse m'a un peu donné le tournis.
On passe à l'illusion suivante, baptisée le mur de café.
À première vue, ce mur composé de carreaux
noirs et blancs est un peu biscornu.
Et c'est vrai que le carreleur aurait pu utiliser une équerre et un niveau.
Et pourtant, croyez-le ou non,
Chaque bande qui le compose est parfaitement rectiligne.
C'est ça, oui. Mon oeil !
Cette illusion a été étudiée par l'équipe du chercheur
Richard Gregory en 1979.
Lorsque l'un d'entre eux découvre ce carrelage dans un café à Bristol,
en Angleterre.
C'est lui qui a donné son nom à cette illusion, le mur de café.
Alors pourquoi, avons nous l'impression
que ces bandes ne sont pas droites
alors que tout est parfaitement aligné ? Et bien ici,
Ce sont les différences de contraste qui bernent notre cerveau.
En effet, lorsque l'aire visuelle située dans le cerveau
reçoit des informations en provenance de nos yeux,
elle commence par analyser les contrastes et les contours,
pas les couleurs.
Or, dans cette image, les contours sont marqués par de très fines lignes grises.
Ce sont elles qui perturbent notre cerveau.
S'il distingue facilement la différence entre le blanc et le gris,
il a plus de mal à faire la différence entre le noir et le gris.
Résultat : nous n'arrivons pas à savoir ou s'arrête le contour des carreaux.
Ainsi, l'enchaînement des carreaux noirs et blancs ne semble plus aligné.
Ce qui donne l'impression que les bandes ne sont pas rectilignes.
Renversant, non ?
Vous en voulez encore ?
Allez, en voici une petite dernière.
l'Échiquier d'Adelson,
du nom de son inventeur,
un neuroscientifique américain.
Regardez attentivement les cases A et B.
La case A semble plus foncée que la case B.
Et pourtant, je vous l'assure, elles sont du même gris.
Mais alors, pourquoi les voit on si différentes ?
Eh bien, l'explication est simple
Notre cerveau se dit
que l'ombre du cylindre vert a légèrement assombri la case B.
Pour lui, cette case est blanche.
Il va donc l'éclaircir mais en réalité, cette ombre est factice.
Les carrés qui entourent la case B sont foncés.
Ce contraste renforce l'impression de notre cerveau.
Il est persuadé que la case B est plus claire qu'elle ne l'est.
Et comme ce n'est pas la première fois qu'il voit un échiquier,
l'alternance de cases claires et foncées, lui semble logique.
Si vous n'êtes toujours pas convaincus,
eh bien je vous montre cette image.
Mais en reliant cette fois les cases A et B,
maintenant, c'est évident, elles sont bien de la même couleur.
En fait, pour interpréter le monde, notre cerveau s'appuie toujours
sur ce qu'il connaît !
Conclusion vous venez de le voir.
Notre perception du monde est toujours modulée par notre cerveau,
notre éducation ou encore notre culture.
Mais comme moi,
je suis sûr que vous avez pris un malin plaisir
à vous laisser berner par les apparences.
Alors, si vous souhaitez voir d'autres illusions d'optique,
n'hésitez pas à faire des propositions en commentaire.
Et puis, si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
eh bien likez et abonnez-vous.
À très bientôt, les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.